things a little differently today and
show you the presentation I made to the
long vest gathering in Montreal I called
it the age of the polyglot similar to a
presentation or at least a video I made
here not too long ago and I wanted to
point out that I think we have always
been polyglots if we look at
hunter-gatherer societies in the world
today in the Brazilian jungle or in the
Papua New Guinea there's like literally
hundreds of languages obviously those
people have to be polyglots to
communicate with their neighbors I think
it was always that way I like history
and if we look at the ancient Persian
Empire for example there were so many
languages coexisting there obviously
people were learning and speaking each
other's languages similarly in China as
China gradually expanded they expanded
and spread the Chinese language and they
had to be able to communicate with
people who spoke other languages as was
the case in the Roman Empire it often
meant that the dominant power had their
language sort of superimposed on another
language so initially people were
speaking various languages and then they
learned a new language or developed a
new language which included the language
of the dominant power the same was true
in the Byzantine Empire lots of
polyglots particularly at the government
level i happen to be interested in you
know ukraine and russia and so there you
have people intermingling with the
steppe people communicating with
constantinople eventually it leads to
lithuania conquering much of what became
ukraine yet in the at the same time they
became speakers of a sort of a mixture
of ukrainian and and belarusian until
they formed their union with the poles
but you know a holy roman empire where
they spoke german and various Slavic
languages
the Persian Empire which extended into
the Caucasus the Ottoman Empire of
course which had people speaking very
many different languages people were
mixing the austro-hungarian Hungarian
and of course the leaders like Maria
there's a others folk of rowdy languages
polyglots have been around for a long
time and the most popular languages that
people learn today seem to be the
European languages around the world
because of colonialism these European
languages or Arabic in the case of the
Arab conquests or China because of their
expansion within China a small number of
languages have become dominant
but many languages subsist and I
remember when I moved to Canada in 1951
on a steamship and that's how times have
changed my mother tried to teach me
English and she had a picture book with
lots of pictures and the only thing I
remember and I still remember is the
word for petunia I learned French in
school in school systems in Montreal
didn't learn much here's a quote from a
TEFL website where they claim that the
lack of qualified English language
instructors is one of the largest
challenges to educators and citizens
across the globe which is a dramatic
overstatement of the importance of
English and the importance of qualified
instructors people learn languages
mostly on their own people become
polyglots on their own I learned four
languages of Asia starting with Chinese
back in the day of the open real Cosette
in Hong Kong I learned Mandarin Chinese
I learned Japanese and focused on some
favourite content such as this NHK
series on the history of the Showa era
and of course I have other many many
other materials which enable me to learn
languages on my own without these
qualified instructors that the British
Council is so concerned about
and I learned languages other than
English of course because I'm a native
speaker of English and today of course
there is so much opportunity to learn
other languages Netflix is
super-powerful our browser extension
which enables us to create lessons out
of Netflix movies I'm enjoying it for
Turkish but there are audiobooks there's
so much out there that we don't need
that quote qualified instructor
although there's nothing wrong with
having them or her it's not necessary we
can learn on our own we can google for
grammar the traditional language learner
very often is a studying only English in
certainly in the English air in the
French school system in Canada they
learn English and the English school
system that in French in Japan they
learned English it seems to be one
language and everybody's worried about
making mistakes and in reality we are in
the age of the polyglot where he
explored languages for our own reasons
we connect with other people who are
interested in languages such as at the
launch fest in Montreal the goal is in
many cases to discover the language to
communicate in the language to explore
the language but not necessarily be
perfect in the language to engage to
enjoy and once you become a polyglot and
have a number of languages you can't
speak them all the time you may look get
stronger in one for a while and then
fall back you need to have a lot of
input because you can't be talking to
twenty different language speakers all
the time you've got to be a bit of a
dilettante and the old myths about you
have to travel to the country is not
true and getting a girlfriend or a
boyfriend is not necessarily true
because once you've got 20 languages it
can make you pretty busy if you try to
get a girlfriend or a boyfriend in every
one of the languages that you speak so
that's kind of a quick run-through of
what I presented in Montreal